Oh John Charlie hi hi I have to say this
is a welcome break for me oh I've been
seeing just a bunch of really good it's
gross sweaty gross men all day it's just
kind of like someone opened a window in
the attic and there's flowers like a
floral sorry what is this regarding of
course let's go right to business why I
get to know each other uh listen I do
actually have a little bit of business
and this does not come from me no this
has not come for me anything coming
coming from me is gonna be sprayed with
Cologne and starting with dear my love
some of the people uh watching the
fights think you dress your dress
provocative they think your dress too
provocative provocative hell um some
people again not me are saying that you
look like you're the hostess at a [ __ ]
Benihana somebody else said that you
look like a milkmaid that works at Hot
Topic and a third man from Bloomington
Indiana says you look like AC skank what
you look like AC skank again I could not
disagree more and if I do agree it's in
the good way all right well this is a
big double standard because Zangief he
fights with boots and a speedo on butt
zangief's special move is not flipping
upside down opening his legs and
spinning for everybody to see your
business you mean my spinning bird kick
yeah I just had it down as the making
teenage boys horny kick
it's a Kenpo move it brings honor to the
tournament brings boner to the
tournament no honor
boner no I said honor make more sense if
he said boner I'm just saying the only
way it could be more inappropriate as if
your tights wear pink can you paint it
or labia on your crotch what don't get
me wrong I love it well it's one of my
moves and I don't think it's
inappropriate Chumlee listen I love the
move I love the move but you know we're
trying to appeal to a wide range of
demographics religious beliefs
conservative values so you know if you
want to keep doing it you might want to
put on like a pair of slacks no I'm not
doing that I don't think it's
inappropriate this is my traditional
Chinese cheap house yep
it's how you use your traditional
outfits like these are traditional work
khakis
but if I stood up and took out my penis
and flapped around just call it my
special move well you might get a
complaint or two maybe not for me maybe
that's something you'd like to know no
that's not no this is ridiculous I'm the
strongest woman in the world
and the hottest look let me run this
upstairs see what I can do in the
meantime that is my home number call me
anytime if a woman answers hang up call
back in 10 minutes okay by the way I
love your buttons what your buns I love
your abs I also love your candy ass I'm
so sorry okay
wait one more Oh just so you know
anytime what I'm trying to say the
headline of this whole interaction is I
am down for some fun in the Chen
she's so hot